a lot of people have been asking me what
I think about the weird UFO sightings
popping up all over the country
Apparently one of the aircraft that we
shot down is shaped like a cylinder and
another one is shaped like an octagon
and people want to know is it the
Chinese is it aliens do aliens exist
Politico is reporting that UFO fever has
gripped Washington DC and so since
people keep asking I'll tell you my main
thought is that 50 Freight cars derailed
on Friday night in Ohio near the
Pennsylvania border leaking according to
reports at least a million pounds of
vinyl chloride which is an extremely
dangerous chemical and a known
carcinogen the safe exposure limit for
vinyl chloride is less than one part per
million after the derailment workers use
small explosives to blow a hole in the
rail cars to drain the vinyl chloride
which they collected in a trench and
then set on fire which seems to have
made an already enormous problem much
much worse because burning Vinyl
chloride since hydrochloric acid into
the air along with phosgene which you
may recall from history class is one of
the poison gases used during World War
One
seems like a pretty important news story
and yet it's not getting very much
coverage
we've just got UFO fever we're not we're
not really paying attention to these
other stories at least one reporter from
news Nation who tried to cover the story
in Ohio was actually arrested on the
scene
what are you trying foreign
pretty weird and while I am mildly
interested in China's latest Espionage
activities in the United States
I don't really care all that much about
UFOs
aliens aren't real
vinyl chloride is
and yet which one is everybody talking
about I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Noel show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on Friday is from salty Walt who
says Donald Trump wants used to say that
he could shoot someone on Fifth Avenue
in broad daylight and not lose a single
vote at this point I wouldn't be
surprised to find out that George Santos
actually did shoot someone on Fifth
Avenue the man is Teflon love the show
keep it up such a good point that guy it
seems like nothing can harm him he seems
completely impenetrable completely
immune when you want to keep your immune
system and your health up you gotta
check out Jace medical right now go to
jacemedical.com enter code Knowles if
the past couple of years has taught you
anything it should be that our supply
chain is incredibly Fragile the FDA just
declared a global shortage of medication
and warned the critical antibiotics are
an extremely short supply across the
United States we all had a good laugh
when when there was a toilet paper
shortage at the start of the covid
lockdowns then when there was a baby
formula shortage things weren't so funny
what about when there's a shortage of
emergency medications like ibuprofen
basic stuff you need to be prepared for
anything and our new partners at Jace
medical are here to help Chase medical
helps you get a long-term supply of
prescription medication a great way to
start preparing is with the Jace case
it's a pack of five different courses of
antibiotics that you can use to treat a
whole host of bacterial illnesses
including UTIs respiratory infections
sinusitis skin infections and more all
you've got to do is fill out a simple
online form your information will be
reviewed by board certified position
your medication will be dispensed by a
licensed pharmacy at a fraction of the
regular cost be like the noses okay get
prepared with the Jace case gives you
peace of mind knowing that your family
will have what you need during a crisis
I want you to be prepared for anything
so go to jacemedical.com enter code
Knolls at checkout for a discount on
your order get that peace of mind go to
jacemedical.com promo code Knowles
aliens aren't real
I know
that's a controversial observation to
make in this they're not real
they're they there is no evidence there
is zero evidence
empirical
or evidence that we can deduce
from our limited observations about the
natural world using human reason zero
evidence that extraterrestrial aliens
exist at all some people say
that the universe is really really big
therefore aliens must exist that is a
non-sequitur it does not follow from the
universe is really really big that
aliens exist
the reason that people believe in aliens
now when people didn't used to believe
in aliens is not because of any new
scientific discovery there has been zero
exactly zero scientific discovery that
would suggest any increased likelihood
for the existence of aliens some people
will say well it's so large that
statistically there have to be aliens
that's not how statistics work
you might be able to make that argument
it might be somewhat persuasive if we
knew anything about the physical origins
of life we do not so there is zero
reason to believe that life certainly
not conscious life has cropped up
anywhere else in the universe it doesn't
matter how big the universe is the
universe could be infinite there would
not be any logical reason to believe
that it life's existence here
would would imply life elsewhere
this is a way for atheists and agnostics
to express religious longing and wonder
people will say well you you religious
people you believe in angels and demons
that's true there is much much more
evidence for Angels and Demons than
there is for extraterrestrial aliens
I don't want to belabor the point I'm
just so sick of the stupid UFO alien
stuff there's there's much much more
evidence for Angels and Demons because
angels and demons are pure spirit
that is the definition of what an angel
and a demon is and so if you believe
that spiritual things exist at all if
you believe that the human person has a
soul if you believe that some things
don't have a rational Soul like animals
and rocks and trees and stuff and that
certain beings do exhibit a rational
Soul then the fact that the soul exists
could imply that there are beings that
are purely spiritual not purely physical
like
like rocks and stuff not hylomorphic
Body and Soul like human beings but pure
Spirit as well there is no the the
suggestion that aliens exist
pose certain theological problems
pertaining to the fall and Redemption of
the world
uh which is a discussion I suppose for
another time because it's somewhat
involved but all of which to say the
thing that everybody is focused on right
now is almost certainly not real and the
problems that we're ignoring are real so
what are the UFOs
according to the U.S Federal Aviation
Administration
we've got lots of weird UFOs flying
above our heads and I love how last week
there was UFO fever and we found out it
was a Chinese spy balloon and we found
another Chinese spy balloon then we
found out that the Chinese have a number
of aircraft that we had not previously
detected flying over U.S airspace and
then a week later
we shoot down some aircraft and the
Pentagon won't give us too much
information about it and everyone says
well it's got to be ET
not that it's obviously more Chinese
aircraft the likes of which we were
seeing all of last week no no it's got
to be something totally different here
we go baby this is it the alien invasion
is on people only believe in the Alien
Invasion because they have given up the
other and more correct version of
eschatology the end of times so people
used to look up to the sky and wait for
the four horsemen to start flying down
in Christ to descend for the second
coming that used to be their vision of
the end of the world but now because
people have thrown away they've
convinced themselves that it's somehow
unreasonable to believe in true and
traditional religion now we're just
waiting for E.T to come down in a flying
saucer and zap the white house because
that's apparently more reasonable than
the uh True Religion that has animated
our civilization uh for two thousand
years yeah okay uh we had a potential
object detected over Montana Saturday
night
the military shot down a cylindrical
object over Alaska it was about the size
of a small car so it was smaller than
those Chinese balloons last week
no aliens yet we can look at Area 51 but
no aliens have been discovered yet
a related point to my point about the
chemical spill in Ohio
we know that there is a little green man
type of alien that is causing lots of
trouble to our country
and yet we ignore that problem
and we we worry about the imaginary
little green men who don't exist and
don't post any problem to our country
there are millions of of aliens pouring
into our country every single year some
of them have tattooed their faces
entirely green and they're members of a
gang called MS-13 but we kind of ignore
that issue we don't really talk about
that one too much in the establishment
media because instead we're going to
distract ourselves with the E.T
people like to distract themselves with
Fantastical stories because it gives
them it gives them something to focus
their attention and worry on that they
can't actually do anything about we
could do something about our Southern
border and stop the little green aliens
who are currently coming in
we could do something about that but we
can't muster the political will to do it
we can't muster the political Unity
that's necessary to do that and so we
have to distract ourselves with
imaginary problems about which there is
nothing that one can possibly do
this is a real Temptation in our culture
you're seeing this right now from Mr
Dylan Mulvaney probably one of the
greatest examples of it who has had he's
the he's the transvestite who was a
Broadway actor and then he pretended to
be a woman and and on Tick Tock every
single day he says that's day five of
being a woman and I'm today I'm flitting
around as a sort of a caricature of what
a woman is I've cried 10 times today
I've never felt more like a woman well
Dylan Mulvaney has had some surgery to
make his face look more like Bruce
Jenner's and now he is posting videos
saying that he looks super duper hot
stay 335 of being a girl and I wanted to
go on record to say that this might be
the hottest I've ever looked and will
ever look in my lifetime
and I'm making this video so that in
thousands of years there will be
evidence is it the dress
it could be the dress it is it the
makeup or is it the hair because I think
it's the extensions and when I have
extensions in I don't know my name I
don't know where I live I just know that
I love these and I know that I look like
I could steal a husband but I want to
promise you look me in the eyes I want
to promise you that I would never do
that to you okay I am a girls girl and I
love you
whew but seriously this is good right
okay okay okay love you love you okay
uh uh much much to say about that video
because it's not just Dylan it reflects
a lot of the problems in our culture but
before we do that before we clear the
air about all that you got to clear the
air in your home that's why you need
rabbit air right now go to rabbitair.com
tell them that Michael Knowles sent you
I think maybe the whole show has led to
this moment not just this episode I mean
the whole show because you know I love
my cigars one of the problems is when
you smoke a cigar indoors a smell tends
to linger okay until now I am so happy
that we have rabbit air on board I've
got my rabbit air award-winning air
purifier in my office so I can smoke in
my office whenever I want and not get
yelled at too much even if you're not a
cigar guy though this air purifier is
just magnificent I live here in
Nashville it's the allergen capital of
the world well rabbit air has advanced
six stage filtration and deodorization
that can reduce Airborne particles odors
and pollutants to keep your air clean
and fresh this air purifier is highly
customizable it's got an interchangeable
face plate design wall mount floor stand
for custom filtration options such as
odor remover for cigars or toxin
absorber for vocs the rabbit air app
lets me monitor air quality control
purification from anywhere at the touch
of a button go to rabbitair.com right
now to speak to a rabbit air consultant
r-a-b-b-i-t-a-i-r.com tell them that
Michael Knowles sent you Dylan Mulvaney
has just given the best proof yet that
transgenderism broadly or at very least
the type of transgenderism that he
suffers from
is a sexual fetish it's what the
psychologist Ray Blanchard called Auto
gynophilia
Ray Blanchard the psychologist said that
there are two kinds of people who think
that they're the opposite sex there are
homosexual transsexuals who are
attracted exclusively to men
and are feminine in both behavior and
appearance and then there are Auto
gynophilic transsexuals who experience
sexual arousal at the idea of having a
female body
it would appear
well Dylan Mulvaney might have
he might have a little touch of both I
guess but but he certainly has the
latter
in as much as he is viewing himself as a
hot sexual object he's saying I've never
looked hotter in my whole life ladies
and it's a funny line and he's saying it
with the dead pan of a trained actor
but
it it does prove the point he's saying I
am looking on my body that some surgeon
has constructed for me with lust
and then
he goes further and he says when I'm
looking at me in my hot new body in the
mirror I don't know my name I forget who
I am I forget where I am all I know is I
just think these hair extensions are
really hot
all of this is an admission of what
conservatives have said about
transgenderism from the beginning which
is this is obviously a sexual fetish
and this is obviously an expression of
self-hatred
that's what he's saying he's saying oh I
just feel such relief I'm so happy
because I forget who I am I'm so happy I
forget my name
I just forget where I am I'm escaping
from a reality that I don't want to
confront into a fantasy and a delusion
that that is relieving my sense of
contempt for for the real world and also
arousing me sexually it's just a total
Vindication of what the conservatives
have said the lips have said no no
transgenderism is just it's just who you
really are it's just people living their
true lives authentically and loving
themselves Dylan Mulvaney saying no no
way man I hate myself I want to forget
who I am I don't want to know my own
name
I want to forget I want to forget where
I am I don't I don't want to remember
anything about the real world
I just want to pursue my sexual desire
to a state of a kind of sexual ecstasy
that's what he's saying he's saying
we're right
and and we have been right about this
the the self-hatred problem is a big
problem very often the the culture of
body positivity or love yourself or or
Pride which is the Primal sin the queen
of all vices and the vice of all queens
is my friend Andrew Cleveland has
pointed out uh is a mask for self-hatred
very often the people who are most
boastful who seem most narcissistic and
egotistical paradoxically they also are
filled with the most self-hatred you're
seeing this reflected in
all of the popular culture but look at
this cartoon that we played last week or
the week before proud family which is a
reboot of a 20 year old cartoon a proud
family has been rebooted to push BLM and
woke intersectional leftists nonsense
and to push onto a culture of
predominantly white people the sense
that white people are evil
how do you understand love don't you no
no I do not understand anything about
white fragility my virginity what's that
supposed to mean you know what it means
you're doing it right now do what being
defensive about race Robert D'Angelo
wrote a whole book about it read it yet
again
same um cover and everything
my dad wouldn't even look at the diary
he said his people would never own
slaves
you can just dismiss me like that white
fertility oh brother Kwame
white fragility that's what it is
now it would be very easy
to say that all of this anti-white
propaganda is just a problem coming from
black people or from non-white people
that's not primarily what's going on
all of the anti-white if you're if
you're a little boy and you're white
you're evil you need to apologize for
your whiteness
that stuff is largely coming from white
people
it's it's not so simple as to say Hey
you radical black people need to stop
pushing this on this it's largely white
people the book that they referenced is
by Robin D'Angelo Robin D'Angelo is a
white lady
the people who run these networks
pushing all this stuff are by and large
white people
and it's
white people who who want to hate
themselves I'm I'm very lucky I don't
know maybe I got a vaccine when I was a
kid or something I am completely immune
to white guilt maybe it's because the
Italians are a sort of racially liminal
people always been a little bit
ethnically ambiguous so I just I just
don't feel it at all
I feel the shame of my sinfulness I feel
a healthy fear of Temptation because
this is a fallen world and we're all
born with original sin though I feel
confident that that won't that won't
destroy my life and send me down to
Perdition because one's soul is cleansed
in in baptism I that's that's kind of my
view of the whole problem but for for
the modern liberals
who ignore that who ignore True Religion
who ignore the wisdom of the ages and of
Revelation who it's not that they become
much more
empirical and grounded in their views
they actually became much they become
much more Fantastical and superstitious
in their views they they can infer
and into it that something is wrong
about this world they they recognize
that there is such a thing as original
sin they just don't want to call it that
so they've got to call it something else
they recognize that something is wrong
with themselves but they don't they
don't
have any path toward Redemption and so
it just leads them further and further
down this pit and they blame it on their
skin color they blame it on whiteness or
they blame it on their their
sexual expression they blame it on an
alleged conflict between their gender
identity and their sex so they chop
themselves up and they mutilate
themselves and they they do that
spiritually and they do that physically
in the case of Dylan Mulvaney and it's
all
it's all just a road right down the pit
there's no there's no getting out of
that it's just it's just more and more
self-hatred compounding on itself
you saw this in the Super Bowl yesterday
I barely saw any of the Super Bowl
yesterday I went to my friend's Super
Bowl party which is very fun I watched
about five seconds of the game I decided
on the drive over there I said which
team do I support I don't I don't know
the Eagles I'm from the Northeast so
maybe the Eagles except that Philly's
pretty rough right now you know Wawa
left Philly it's a pretty crime-ridden
hellscape so I don't know if I would
support the Phillies and then I thought
the chiefs were starting a sweet little
Elise about this the Chiefs at least
that name is slightly more Politically
Incorrect right are you allowed to call
something the Chiefs these days so that
kind of made me like them I heard one of
the guys on the Chiefs is a strong
Christian conservative guy I don't even
know if that's true or not but I said
okay I guess I'll support the Chiefs
then we tune in one of the first things
one sees
the black national anthem
[Music]
foreign
agree with the home
[Music]
okay we can cut it off there my favorite
part of this entire charade is as this
woman is singing this ridiculous song
that nobody had heard of until five
minutes ago it cuts to it the black guys
who are standing there and they just
look miserable they're like oh man do I
this doesn't mean anything to me this is
a completely contrived tradition no
why do I have to but because I'm a black
guy I gotta
and then it cuts to the white guy next
to him he's like what are we what is
this why do I have to be here was this
over yet can we can we get on to the
real national anthem but now the libs
are saying
there are two national anthems
one for black people one for white
people
which one do the Hispanics and the
Asians and the other people I don't know
which one they get to sing maybe they'll
get their own
but if there were two national anthems
that means that there are two Nations
two competing nations are they going to
be geographically distinct Nations is is
the is what the lib's saying here is
that black people need one part of the
country and white people need another
part of the country or is it going to be
two Nations fighting over the same
geographical land is it the libs calling
for a race war
those are the only options if you have
two national anthems
for two distinct groups of people within
the same Geographic territory
then you're either calling for partition
like you saw with India and Pakistan or
you're calling for a race war from one
group to conquer the other in the in the
geographical Terror that's the only
thing that that can mean
and so you see the singer whoever she is
singing this made-up song and
you see all these other people
of all different races behind her
looking very uncomfortable
and slightly bored and just largely
confused that's the right expression you
should be uncomfortable with this this
idea
does not end well
you know if you have questions about the
black national anthem or any other
question you can send it in the
voicemail bag
that's right we've got the voicemail
back coming up on Friday how do you do
it you go to dailywire.com First you go
to dailywire.com Knowles enter code
knowledge you become a daily wire member
then you go to the show page you click
watch you scroll down to the Michael
Knowles show
click on the Michael Knowles show click
into
the mailbag and then it opens up an
email and then you just attach an audio
file whether it's from your computer you
can record it on your phone keep it to
under a minute I'm begging you because
otherwise it's very difficult for us to
play it on the show then you send it in
we get to hear your dulcet tones on
Friday very very exciting
speaking of the Super Bowl Super Bowl
was not all that bad I am told I I
didn't even make it to halftime I left I
had to get the kids to sleep I had to do
some work so I left early but I did see
some clips of halftime and the big story
from halftime is that Rihanna who is the
performer is pregnant
which I thought was great you know that
the guys who organized the Super Bowl
were Furious about this because they
they signed the contract I assumed
before Rihanna got pregnant certainly
before Rihanna was showing that she was
pregnant
there hadn't been a big announcement
that this singer was pregnant and so
they say oh no we got this
pregnant we hate pregnancy we hate kids
there's overpopulation we got we got
we're pushing abortion our singer's
pregnant now she's probably not gonna
do his like a weird sexually
charged dance that would be really
because that would be pretty awkward
wouldn't it the show it was one of the
tamest halftime shows we've seen in
years
and people were celebrating probably not
the organizers of the Super Bowl but
everybody else they said they were so
happy for Rihanna as they should have
been uh Philip Lewis
who is an editor for The Huffington Post
he's the senior front page editor he
tweeted out he said Rihanna performed
the Super Bowl halftime show while
pregnant with second child
representative confirms
my first reaction was
it's a child again is it
that's amazing because I was told
previously
I was reliably informed by the sort of
people who work at The Huffington Post
that when a baby is in the womb it's not
a baby
it's not a child
it's not alive it's not human it's just
a meaningless clump of cells
certainly we are told that when poor
women get pregnant
that that's a meaningless clump of cells
you should go kill that so you can get
back to work at the widget Factory
certainly we are told that when
desperate women who do not have
adequate support to raise a child
without some degree of difficulty and
suffering when they get pregnant oh you
should just go kill it you're not even
killing it's not even a baby just go
it's a simple medical procedure it's a
clump of cells don't even look at it
it's okay just get it done but then when
Rihanna is pregnant well that's one
that's a child
it's a child when wealthy people want
babies
and they get pregnant then that's a
child the royal baby whenever a duchess
gets pregnant it's never the Royal fetus
it's never the Royal Club itself it's
always the royal baby he's going to be
born in six months
it's just when poor people when the
deplorables when the irredeemables when
the bitter clinging Bible thumping no
good useless people like some
contributors to the world economic Forum
calls them when they get pregnant when
you get pregnant
then you should kill it nobody wants
that Rihanna though that's great I'm
glad I'm glad even The Huffington Post
can admit it that's a great that's a
great new change speaking of things
growing inside of people great news for
John Federman the senator from
Pennsylvania the gigantic bulbous uh
growth on his neck has apparently gone
away
this was one of the reasons that John
Federman was wearing a lot of hoodies
during the campaign is he had this giant
very concerning growth on his neck but
John fetterman didn't want to ask any or
answer rather any questions about his
health while he was on the campaign
Trail and so they just kind of covered
it up as best they could and now the
growth is gone which I'm sure is
actually a very very good thing
but John fetterman continues to have
health problems uh we we saw over the
last week John fetterman was admitted to
the hospital George Washington
University hospital because he was
feeling lightheaded at a fundraiser John
Federman uh thought that he might be
having another stroke apparently and so
they went in gave him a CT CTA MRI tests
they ruled out a stroke which is good
news his EEG tests came back normal
and no evidence of any seizures which
they had been concerned about but John
fetterman is not doing well back in the
fall John Federman was talking about
football he was talking about the Eagles
who were in the Super Bowl and here here
was here was a pretty
simple answer about football that he
tried to formulate
[Applause]
so presumably he was trying to say the
Eagles are better than the Steelers or
the Steelers are better than the Eagles
who didn't obviously didn't come out
very well I really am not making fun of
the guy the guy obviously has brain
damage and continues to have that the
New York Times is reporting on that the
New York Times reported that fetterman
has been left with serious mental health
issues he often cannot understand the
words that other people are saying as a
result of the stroke he has to use live
audio to text transcription for
everything that he does
certainly in his work as a senator and
then apparently when fetterman is under
stress and being a national level
politician is a stressful job he says
that trying to understand what other
people are saying is like quote trying
to make out the muffled voice of the
teacher in the Peanuts cartoon whose
words could never be deciphered
according to this report in the times so
really bad situation it is cruel that
the libs have put him into the Senate
and that his wife is tolerating this
it's cruel because it is allowing him to
be humiliated every single day not by
mean right-wing comedians not by gotcha
journalists just he has to speak
sometimes as a U.S senator and it is
humiliating because he isn't able to to
form coherent sentences if you've ever
known a stroke victim you know this is
this is heartbreaking when when people
want to say something and they can't say
something or when they can't quite
understand what people are saying to
them and so
many people are are observing that this
man is not fit to be a U.S senator
and that's the only part that I disagree
with
I agree that it's cruel and wrong to put
him in the U.S Senate I think his family
should be ashamed of themselves I think
the Democratic party should be ashamed
of itself
for many other reasons but that one too
but he's not unfit to be a senator
because he doesn't really have to do
anything as a senator his staff can just
vote for him
a hundred years ago being a senator
meant more than it does today 200 years
ago being a senator certainly meant more
than it does today
a lot of the Senate's power is just gone
though and the Senate and the House of
Representatives have just shipped that
power away to bureaucrats in the
executive agencies to the leadership in
the Senate and leadership in the House
of Representatives
to
to International supernational bodies
that control a lot of U.S policy
they've just given it away and it was
their right to give it away I know there
are some people who are real antagonists
of the administrative State and the real
small government conservatives and they
say the Congress had no right to
delegate away these Powers but I'm not
convinced by that necessarily
I think the Congress has brought power
to delegate away its responsibilities
and it has all the incentive to do
because
if Congress and the Senate are voting on
legislation then it's going to open them
up to attacks
if they say well we're only voting on
one or two bills a year we're going to
vote on the Omnibus we're going to vote
on a defense authorization act and
that's pretty much all we're going to do
all year long then it becomes much
easier to go back and campaign and if
that's all you're voting on then then
this guy is just going to be a rubber
stamp in fact even before the stroke he
was running to be a rubber stamp it's
not as though John Federman was a road
scholar okay it's not as though the
health problems are really what
exacerbated John federman's dissent into
this lowest common denominator politics
he was always going to be a rubber stamp
for the whatever the Democrats wanted
and that's what he is now
speaking of the deep state
really bad news over the over the
weekend for
anybody who wants Western Civilization
to have any hope of coming out of its
current pit as we continue to slide into
the pit and this is because
American liberals
are going into Hungary
to try to oust the very successful
good conservative leader of Hungary
Samantha power in particular one of
those Barack Obama faces of the swampy
liberal deep State Samantha powers on
the ground in Hungary relaunching a U.S
aid program in that country
as usaid administrator I have the chance
to travel all around the world to engage
with people who are working every day to
strengthen Democratic institutions to
build Independent Media and to promote
and protect human rights I'm here in
Hungary one of the countries in Central
Europe where usaid has recently
relaunched programming to tackle just
these challenges I'm going to spend the
next couple days engaging with
hungarians about their vision for a
brighter future
I've only met Samantha Powers once it
was when I was this is one of my first
jobs after college I was a fake
sommelier at George sorosa's wedding
I mentioned that one of the stranger
political stories that I have one of my
pieces of evidence by the way that
George Soros doesn't totally control the
world is that if they had even Googled
me beforehand they never would have
hired me for this job but I Met George
soros's wedding and there are all sorts
of very liberal power players in the
room some celebrities like Bono Nancy
Pelosi International political power
players like Christine negarde from from
then the IMF now she's the World Bank
and Samantha power Samantha power was
one of the big Obama people who made it
to George soros's wedding she's just
she's swampy and Samantha power
is there on behalf of usaid which is the
U.S agency for International Development
independent agency of the federal
government responsible for administering
civilian foreign aid and development
assistance they got a budget of 27
billion dollars it's one of the largest
official Aid agencies in the world it
accounts for more than half of all U.S
foreign assistance
for uh for the highest in the world in
terms of absolute dollars
now she's going into Hungary
not Syria not Libya not North Korea
Hungary
this is one of the ways in which the
United States pushes its Imperial power
around the world to try to oust
governments
Samantha power is on the ground now in
Hungary on behalf of the Biden
Administration to launch a color
Revolution to oust Victor Orban because
Victor Orban is too conservative and
successful Victor Orban he he governs a
relatively small country but he has
done more than any leader in the west
probably to turn around the the negative
Trend and try to get his country back on
the right track you can see this
aesthetically Victor Orban has gotten
rid of the crappy brutalist communist
art and architecture and he's tried to
re-butify make the country more ornate
more human more Western more more
beautiful I know this seems like a minor
point but we're talking about goodness
truth and beauty beauty is a
transcendental too it's very important
to civilization he's he's focused on
that he's turned around much more
practical problems like the dying
population we have a dying population
here in the United States we don't have
enough babies to offset the number of
people who are dying this is one of the
causes of mass migration this is true
throughout the West Victor Orban has
turned his birth rate decline around
they're not yet producing more babies
than people are dying but they've turned
it around pretty significantly and
they're getting close this is one of the
reasons that Victoria Bond can say no to
mass migration he's one of the only
Western leaders to do so
the rest of the West says no flood the
country with foreign Nationals oh what
could go wrong that that won't
destabilize our societies Victor Urban
one of the few just like the hungarians
uh were at some of the most decisive
battles in Western history Victor Orban
says no
no we're not we're going to say no to
that so no to mass migration no to a
dying population we're to support
families we're going to support birth
and no to your crappy modern ideology
and art no we're going to embrace the
best the heights of our civilization and
the libs freaking hate him for it as far
as I'm concerned the age should be going
into the other other direction
digital robot certainly should expel
Samantha power from his country as fast
as he can he should say no thanks to
this instantiation of usaid frankly we
should have Hungarian Aid coming into
the United States because he's got some
answers to some of the big problems
plaguing our society and I think
probably we could we could learn a lot
if the aid we're going in the other
direction to celebrate President's Day
this year the daily wire is launching
our
our president's for sale sale with 40
off new annual memberships the big guy
got 10 percent we're giving you 40 get
access to the world of daily wire plus
with Fearless documentaries gripping
movies Dennis prager's master's program
and the entire library of Dr Jordan
Peterson's work
including new productions Exodus logos
and literacy
on marriage all available to watch right
now coming down the pipeline to a TV or
a laptop near you new episodes of Ben
Shapiro's the search Exodus part 2 are
much anticipated DW kids content and Pen
Dragon later this year to sweeten the
deal we're also giving you up to 40 off
selected items in the daily wire shop
take advantage of our president's for
sale sale today you know that he would
go to dailywire.com subscribe to become
a member today that's dailywire.com
subscribe
speaking of strong right-wing leaders
we got to get to the horse race don't we
we haven't talked about the horse race
in days Trump
versus
DeSantis
it's a new poll out this is from
Monmouth University National poll of
Republican voters
shows you how the Republicans are
thinking about DeSantis and Trump if
this poll is to be believed
and that's a big if
DeSantis is up by 13 points 53 to 40.
now National primary polls don't really
matter because the primary is not held
nationally the primary is held in Iowa
New Hampshire
South Carolina on and on Florida it goes
all around the country and so
momentum changes depending on who's
winning these primary contests
but as of right now I think this poll
tells you something because of the
breakdown of who is supporting whom
among strong Republicans
DeSantis 49 Trump 46. so statistically
about even between Trump and descendants
among strong Republicans among
Republican leaners
DeSantis crushes
60 to 32.
among the very conservative DeSantis is
still winning but by less by
significantly less 53-43
among moderates
DeSantis does better in terms of that
Delta it becomes 51-38
among evangelicals and starts to switch
again the Trump gains a little bit more
into Santa's still winning though 51-44
non-evangelicals DeSantis takes it 56-34
under 65 years old DeSantis destroying
58 to Trump's 37 percent
among 65 plus it flips
Trump beating DeSantis 49-43
among people making more than 50 Grand a
year DeSantis totally crushing it 61 to
33 percent
among people making less than 50 Grand a
year
it flips
Trump wins 53 percent to 38 tells you a
lot
that that's the most interesting poll
I've seen so far on the head-to-head and
by the way this field is going to be
full of people full of people
Mike Pence has already said he's going
to run or at least strongly intimated it
Nikki Haley is all but said she's
running Mike Pompeo has all but said
that he's running
Ted Cruz actually hasn't said very I'm
not I'm not being Coy even though you
know hosted a show with a guy for three
years love him to death close friend of
mine uh he hasn't said anything one way
or the other he said he would be
interested in running but not that he is
planning to but he might
whether you know there are going to be
tons of other people actually there's
one in particular who's a total joke
he's already essentially said that he's
running
what does it tell you though you're
looking at Trump and DeSantis it tells
you
Trump does better with older voters and
lower income voters
and he's roughly even among strong
Republicans
and DeSantis does better with the
moderates and The Independents and the
younger voters and the wealthier voters
that tells you that Trump is in a pretty
good position it doesn't look like he's
in a good position because of the 53 to
40. that looks really bad
but
the lower income voters
disproportionately represent a
republican base
not necessarily the big obviously not
the big donors not necessarily the
people who go to the think tank lunches
but in terms of the Republican base
especially in a post Obama post Joe
Biden world
the base is skewing much more working
class certainly than the Democrats are
and older voters older voters tend to
vote more than younger voters do so if
Trump is doing better among the older
voters that is disproportionately going
to help him
so you might look at these numbers say
well DeSantis would do better in the
general that might well be the case but
we're talking about a primary and we're
talking about a primary by the way which
almost certainly won't be Head to Head
so the challenge for DeSantis right now
and I've said this from the beginning
and I've been totally Vindicated on it
DeSantis it has to run in the anti-trump
lane
it's just the race includes Donald Trump
so you could say DeSantis is the most
trumpy candidate in the world he's
trumpier than Trump he's Trump 2.0 you
could say all of that but in a race
where Trump is running DeSantis
necessarily has to be the anti-trump
that's why DeSantis is going to attract
support from some squishes and that's
why he's going to attract support from
some centrists and some Libs
and that could hurt him so he's got to
walk this tightrope it's very very
difficult and then when you add other
candidates to it all of a sudden now
Trump with all of his name recognition
with his 40 Years of celebrity is going
to perform even better in fact that's
what happened in 2016. if you're
counting Trump out I just think it's way
way too early to do that why are all
these candidates going to run because
the landscape is really really strong
for Republicans right now according to a
to another Monmouth poll this from uh
last Monday
39 of Americans said that the state of
the union is strong
this is right before Joe Biden gave a
State of the Union Address
less than 40 percent
of Americans believed that the state of
the union is strong 58 say the state of
the union is not strong
32 percent say the union is not too
strong 26 percent say it's not at all
strong that's why the people are getting
into this race
they view Joe Biden as very beatable
and they view Trump as not as formidable
as he previously had been
strong but not strong enough to clear
the field which means paradoxically that
if the field gets flooded with people
Trump might be able to stand out by just
consistently keeping a plurality I'm not
saying that's going to happen DeSantis
or some other candidate might blow him
out of the water within a matter of
months but as of right now that's how it
stands speaking of some of those squishy
Republicans Chris sununu Chris sununu
governor of New Hampshire says that he's
going to run for president or at least
he's strongly implying that he's going
to run for president and
here's his platform
you've been talking about trying to sort
of remind the party that Republicans are
about limited government you said
recently Republicans are almost trying
to outdo Democrats at their own game of
being big government and having a
solution and a say on everything who are
you thinking of when you say oh there's
a lot like I think there's a lot of
leadership out there that forget that
forgets at heart I'm a principled free
market conservative let the markets
decide so there's no individual per se
but there's a lot of leadership that
says you know what when we're not
getting that result out of a private
business or locality uh we'll just
impose from the top down our
conservative will you're not talking
about the Florida governor and Disney
for example that's a bad example yeah
that's that's an example one of the many
Ron DeSantis may be running for
president yeah yeah look Ron's a very
good Governor he is but I'm just trying
to remind folks what we are at our core
and if we're trying to beat the
Democrats at being big government
authoritarians remember what's going to
happen eventually they'll have power in
a state or in a position and then
they'll start penalizing conservative
businesses and conservative nonprofits
and conservative ideas
that is the worst precedent in the world
that's exactly what the founding fathers
tried not to try to avoid
and the award for the most out of touch
Republican goes to drum roll please uh
Governor Chris sununu wow
congratulations
oh my goodness it's as though
Chris sununu he got he was cryogenically
frozen in 2010
or 2009 and he just maybe even earlier
and he froze there and he just was
melted out of that freeze and he said
hey guys
we if we ever use the government the
Liberals might use it against us
oh yeah Chris you must have missed the
last um 10 years really you must have
missed the last um
70 years of U.S politics they're already
doing that
but guys if we do anything to fight back
in the real world then the Democrats
might hypothetically keep doing what
they've been doing for 70 years
yeah yeah that's not a hypothetical then
it's not if we do this then they might
do this that's not the situation we're
in is the libs are already
doing the thing
and the question to us is are we going
to fight back in a just way in accord
with what the founding fathers wanted I
love I love when these people invoke the
founding father they say the founding
fathers would never want us to wield
political power bro what where do you
what are you talking about
we had many many many more social
regulations at the time of the founding
fathers we had many many more social
regulations even 20 years ago than we do
today
we had blasphemy laws on the books for
much of this country's history
we had blue laws all over the place we
had very strict immigration controls for
much of this country's history
we had very strong
[Music]
standards that we enforced with the
weight of the government with the weight
of the state on education on religion on
on social norms between men and women
all of that
what if we if we start listen I'm a
strong conservative I want to cut taxes
yeah life is about more than cutting I
like cutting taxes too but countries are
about more than that life is about more
than that what a waste elect me and I'll
keep using the same loser strategy that
cost us the entire culture wouldn't even
allow conservatives to conserve the
women's bathroom the rest of the show
continues now
you don't want to miss this Mr Davies
who did watch the Super Bowl because he
is a sports fan
he has got the best moments that I may
have missed become a member right now
dailywear.com Knowles use code Knolls to
check out for two months free on all
annual plans see you at the member block
[Music]
all right